okay
come on so what we're seeing is a bunch
of camera Shake that's been stabilized
that's so cool it's the classic green
screen problem of just like all right no
one actually knows what it's going to
look like because they're just looking
at this void of green this as a concept
is one of the craziest things I've seen
are we finally taking a look at the Last
Airbender does this live up to the hype
is this going to be crazy
thanks to noon for sponsoring this video
stick around to figure out how you can
take your free Noom evaluation
welcome back to visual effects artists
react
this is this is a special episode
because there's no guests and what does
that mean well it means we have to let
loose a little bit you know today we're
bringing back the bad in good and bad
CGI and we have a lot of really good
stuff to go through I'm ready let's get
into it
I always knew you returned
oh my God are we finally taking a look
at the Last Airbender so we've had a lot
of requests to take a look at the Last
Airbender it's known as not being a very
good movie but more so it's known for
just completely like disrespecting the
original Source materials
foreign
so I wanted to jump in here and just see
this and see whatever he's talking about
does this live up to the hype is this
going to be crazy Let's uh let's take a
look
in this composition yeah it's framing I
want to imply that he's short so we're
just gonna keep seriously what is up
with this composition this Headroom
there's some things that really jump out
to me so when Aang starts moving the
wind there it's copped around him kind
of like you know they cut him out and
they put some behind him they put some
in front of him but like for some reason
they made it the same color as the
ground like I kind of get it like you
know it's dust right but is he an
earthbender an airbender right like why
is his air bending the same color as the
Earth bending so I already right there
you're running into like a bit of a
weird like visual Motif that's not
really being consistent yeah that's kind
of tough though because it's like what
do you color wind you just make it like
white and Misty you know like it treat
it like The Vapor Trails off the edges
of it like a Jet Wing if I was the
director and this is the shot that was
given to me here's what I'd say first
and foremost you have all this dust we
have zero actual debris no leaves no
grass no plants leaves leaves yeah
nothing outside of just literally Brown
smoke like it doesn't even like feel
like air secondly it's not casting any
sort of Shadow like that should be
blocking things like even as you can see
dust kicked out from people's feet they
cast shadow on the ground but this dust
in the air isn't casting any Shadow and
then also literally no one is being
blown around by the wind like his robe
doesn't move the people around him their
robes don't move like nothing gets blown
by wind and he's making a little tornado
leaves would have done so much and also
I agree I see the reasoning behind
coloring it the same as the ground the
problem is that it even can't see it
which is the initial problem to begin
with
doesn't look that bad actually I see
some problems with it already but like
the fire simulation itself looks good I
think it's real fire at the bottom of
the fire pit but notice how there's just
a tiny flame in the bottom and there's a
giant flame in the top and like they
didn't like they didn't bother to
connect the two that's just straight up
the bottom of the fire and the top of
the fire is a completely different size
well it's magic fire problem number two
with the fire there's zero light on the
environment you take the brightest spot
of the fire like that should be
Illuminating things you pull up a real
picture of like a fire jet that that's
that big especially an overcast stay
it's gonna light up things around it
when it comes from like an effect
standpoint the difference between a
sunny day and an overcast day if you're
actually going to like you know take a
meter you're gonna see there's way less
light so the moment you have a huge
bright effect like this you will see
effects of the lighting in the
environment there's another issue that
stands out to me which just it feels
like a lack of reference here there's no
heat ripples from the fire and heat
ripples really aren't that hard to do
you can literally take the exact same
fire element and use it for your heat
ripples but there's just zero so the
Fire doesn't feel hot either heat
ripples is what cells Heat
so this is a we did four pieces based on
the division live action pieces and yeah
that's all real right there those are
real heat ripples that's real fire real
lighting like in heat ripples don't just
distort they also blur yeah the heat
ripples are a lot smaller scale and kind
of sharp than you might expect we also
added some power digitally but because
we have that real reference right there
we could really make it feel like it was
embedded in the scene
this is
and this is a fake shot right here yeah
so all of the fire in that shot is fake
which you did I added them yeah but so
the fact that you went in and put the
heat ripples even if the heat ripples
aren't perfect the fact that they're
there goes so much further to making
this feel like it's a hot scene the
lighting in this alley is still closer
to like that overcast look than you know
indirect Sun
this rock here and which is another CG
object but it doesn't illuminate it at
all oh my God you're right there's
literally zero illumination on that rock
what technique do you use to have a
flame object like this or a simulation
cast light like how would you have done
it back then well I did do it back then
should we pull up my video
oh yeah
so anyway we've entered the roast Zone I
know why do I keep doing this to myself
you've entered the Donk zone so to
answer your question how would you
create the lighting well you could just
literally manually add some orange to
the ground or you can have that you have
the scene already tracked you might as
well render out some geometry on the
ground and the wall and actually have a
light source illuminate it so you render
out a lighting pass of the ground that
you would then use in compositing just
because they have the fire and it's
bright and it looks like it's emitting
light that's really just a Shader it's
not actually an emissive material it's
not actually emitting light so any sort
of lighting in a scene is going to have
to be hacked into it people will say oh
it just looks too CG and that's not
really the problem the problem is that
it doesn't feel like it belongs the
simulation pretty solid yeah it's
actually really pretty solid but the
compositing of that render not so solid
it's like devoid of like all energy and
excitement right I I just have no clue
if this is supposed to be like a scary
scene or a happy scene or an intense I
don't know I came into this thinking
that the effects were actually going to
be pretty solid and it was going to be
the filmmaking that was bad but I think
it's everything isn't as good as I
thought it might be yeah
I wanted to bring in this video because
I thought this had some pretty good
effects in it but they're also kind of
unique Giants
here we go
wait so is he big or small he's regular
size people are tiny
what's going on here like yeah are
pretty detailed like especially this
shot right here where you see the water
going up his back and yeah they actually
did have some sort of stand-in for his
body in the the water Sim this is like
one of those classic green screen shoots
where it's really important to see what
the final product is like going to be or
like at least pre-visualized a little
bit better because you can tell that as
they're lighting this they kind of
weren't totally sure how to handle a
couple elements here like you have this
weird highlight hitting his stomach yet
like the whole background is completely
blocked off by these ships it's the
classic green screen problem of just
like all right no one actually knows
what it's going to look like because
they're just looking at this void of
green that includes the actor but that
also includes the cinematographer who's
gonna have to basically order where the
lights are going to be and then the VFX
are decided upon later sometimes they
make the decision to be like you know
what we're gonna make our own lighting
to make the shot look good even though
that's now different than the lighting
for the actual subject on the green
screen that creates a disconnect and
that is where a lot of the oh it's just
shot on a green screen type takes come
from you know I mean to be that's like
the biggest challenge with green screen
is lighting your green screen element to
match the scene it's actually going to
be composite into I guess we're a big
fan of when we do green screens like an
element on our shoot we do it in the
spot if we can where it'll eventually be
composited into that way the lighting
all matches so pretty for any guys out
there who without a budget you want to
do some green screen do it outside it's
going to look better yeah just get the
little pop-up green screens or get one
of her blankets yeah oh dude yeah get
our black quarter digital that store
lighting matches here the sunlight hits
from the right direction yeah actually
that's a good point this is a very well
connected shot they probably shot a lot
of this movie just like they went out to
the parking lot and were like all right
put the camera really low staring up and
that's the perspective of everyone else
no CG great but then they still put a
whole sky in the background but that's
easy enough to do
Obi-Wan never told you what happened to
your father it's also hard to match like
the aperture difference you know because
it's like he was in focus and they were
kind of out of focus and it definitely
looks like they're trying to make it
work but it's one of those things that's
just very difficult because to film all
of those people at the correct scale you
would also need to film him using the
same scale camera one of the challenges
of filming Miniatures especially you
have a big thing in the shot at the same
time is the smaller something gets the
shallower the depth of field gets like
if you take macro photography for
example you know I can only get like a
sliver of something in focus and
everything goes really out of focus well
imagine you're filming a person that's a
one inch tall person with a regular
camera just think of how big that camera
sensor is relative to the person the
bigger a camera sensor gets the more out
of focus the background and foreground
will get basically the shallower your
depth of field can become if you want
that same effect the person was six feet
tall well your sensor would have to be
10 feet wide by like 10 feet tall which
would give you the correct depth of
field now when you film a six foot tall
person to make them look like they're
one inch tall but obviously the sensor
of that size doesn't exist so they're
avoiding this whole like Focus issue by
just kind of shooting everything in deep
focus deep focus is when everything is
in Focus it's kind of made famous by
Citizen Kane that's kind of one of the
first moves to come out just to be like
all deep focus all the time
foreign
let's take a look at something new so it
was come to my attention actually on the
on our subreddit one of the craziest
things I've seen was posted you make a
film in one language and you want to put
it into another language how do you do
that well generally you dub it you add
subtitles you do all that stuff however
obviously as we know right now there's a
lot of fun AI stuff when it comes to
redoing lip movements facial expressions
all that stuff this movie called The
Champion is basically the first movie to
use AI to visually redub the entire film
into a new language
so size
you can do anything coming down
so be it wow do that lip man that is
subtle that's really good isn't that
freaking crazy
it's been kind myself
I'm not a champion
what do you think the technique is like
from a Layman's person so there is an AI
called Wave 2 lip where basically takes
an audio waveform and makes the lips
move it's not that bad but obviously
it's pretty low res and it only does the
lips so this is what I would assume it's
just doing like a more refined version
of this so what they're doing it's one
level deeper than What wave tulip is
doing wave to lip attempts to guess what
the mouth shapes are going to look like
whereas with this one the way they do it
is they take the actors and then they
redub an English version but it's being
filmed with like three witness cameras
so that way they have a base for what
it's supposed to look like when they're
speaking so if they still have to do the
laborious process of taking the entire
film and redubbing it in English but
then using those cameras they have like
the data of what it looks like when they
speak and then AI magic and then final
film so it's not some random other
person doing the lines on camera it's
the original actor but they fed him the
English line that he was able to just
say yeah and he says that later in a
studio after the film's finally like
edited and they I think they applied to
like the like the final colored rated
footage hypothesis you film up with
three cameras you then take that footage
and project it onto a a model that
allows you to actually align it with the
actor's rotation and then from that
point is where you would use uh like
some of that AI stuff to make the
transfer of one performance onto the
other they could be using the 3D models
for like the extreme angles which you
tend not to get very good results for
when you just do a like a basic deep big
process to them I feel like it'd be way
too labor intensive if you're constantly
having to lie in 3D models yeah and Mike
Seymour made a point of saying that the
process is very streamlined and so they
were able to do hundreds of shots and I
feel like if they're having to do all of
these 3D models of faces and alignment
and stuff like that that's the opposite
of streamlined this as a concept for me
is one of the coolest most positive like
actual tangible benefits we can start to
see with visual AI of all the things you
can use AI for tricking people and
faking things and blah blah it's like
how awesome would it be to like have a
foreign language film that's now
suddenly accessible to anyone or any
language dude I'd love to see this
applied to the show dark on Netflix I
know yes there's so much to look at and
figure out you're constantly like what's
going on and then like you're reading
the subtitles and you look up you're
like what's going on yeah so yeah you're
right it's pretty cool it's pretty neat
we've been very positive about the VFX
on this show lately and you've been
asking us to really break down some bad
V effects so leave a comment down below
with any examples that you thought are
the worst VFX shots of
Charles
come on so I love simple clever visual
effects and the movie Logan has that
when Professor X has a seizure and every
starts going like whoa her brains are
being melted Patrick Stewart was like
you know I know I'm supposed to be going
crazy and losing it but when you guys
are just sitting here pointing a camera
at me and I'm just going like it's like
it just doesn't hit I'm not able to get
into the the headspace you know and he
was like all right what he wants to do
he's like shake the camera and then
everybody's like hmm what if we shook
the camera really hard and stabilize it
afterwards
oh
so what we're seeing is a bunch of
camera Shake that's been stabilized you
see this all the time in actual
stabilized footage we're saying like
there's a motion blur streak that goes
where like the Finish didn't move you're
like where'd that come from it just goes
to show it's not about how crazy your
simulations are it's about your ideas
and how they execute with the story
shaking the camera and stabilizing it
that's all they did that's an effect
that you could do right now with your
phone and like five minutes on the
computer it's that easy do you guys want
to do a shot right now wait wait is that
Professor X okay here we go all right
hear all that I gotta get Sam I gotta
get Sam he's like injector here I'm
gonna use one altered clip too for the
altered AI just so I can say something
hilarious
I'm Professor Rex oh my gosh I'm having
a seizure
[Music]
all better it's worth mentioning that
when you do that effect you need to have
a camera that has Global shutter oh yeah
otherwise you just get the jello rolling
shutter is what it's called which most
cameras including RED cameras black
magic cameras are iPhones they all have
a non-global shutter some some RED
cameras have Global shutter most cameras
have a CMOS sensor which records from
top down so if you're spinning left and
right your image suddenly skews so this
reminds me of Top Gun and how they got
the camera Shake in that movie wait what
the old Top Gun yeah the original Top
Gun movie that came out in the 80s they
were filming Miniatures of the jets
flying by and if they were just shooting
it with the camera they were missing out
on all of that energy and so they came
up with this crazy interesting camera
rig it was a
drill oh really the way they got this
was by taking a drill and taking a block
of wood and putting it on a rod into the
drill but that block of wood was off
center so that when it would spin it
would vibrate it's the exact same
mechanism that makes your video game
controllers vibrate and Rumble yeah so
like the shot for instance it's just a
suspended miniature jet look at that
they're just spinning it yeah yeah they
just turn it on it's literally a button
to get camera Shake oh that's so cool so
Todd biziri shared that bit of knowledge
they could have done that for the Logan
shot as opposed to just like hitting the
camera or just manually trying to shake
it because yeah to keep it that
consistent it's hard the frequency of
the shake is very hard to to get as well
and that's where this is coming in
because it's a very high frequency Shake
I love the idea of having to Wrangle
your camera it's like let's go
but seriously think about like the Logan
stuff like I see this from decades ago
I'm like hey does anyone have a battery
operated drill on standby and it's like
yeah it's like cool I'm taping it to my
shoulder rig it takes what five minutes
to rig an equivalent version the
frequency of like handheld vibration and
shaking it is one thing but when you
have something that can like go above
that like the the look you you can sense
how different it looks would it have
benefited from uh like a drill I I think
it actually probably would have made it
just a little bit more intense but I
don't know because the drill would have
created a very consistent blur but what
I'm seeing here is the blur kind of
flaring out and coming back to normal
again then kind of flaring out and that
inconsistency I don't think is something
that you would get from a drill mounted
type rig unless you weren't going like
rare rare rare rare rare oh my God
you're totally right
what's up everybody I'm back to tell you
about one of my favorite sponsors of
this channel new as you know I've been
using NuMe for months now and it is
literally changed my life and how I
approach food and exercise and
everything see Noom is a science-based
program not a diet it's not a fad diet
it's not a one-off one of the main goals
here is food tracking so I track my food
every day using their color code system
green yellow and red you know you have a
calorie budget you're trying to fit
within that more green Foods is better
than more red foods and just by tracking
it every day helps me make those better
decisions in my everyday life there's
also really great programs I just took a
lesson today about social eating you
know it's kind of hard to pass up on the
extra dessert or pass it up on the extra
Advertiser when you're sitting with a
big group of people so so the lesson I
took today was called Breaking the Habit
and they were teaching me a psych trick
on how to approach social eating a
little bit better you know when you're
eating with a big group of people they
actually say that you eat 65 more than
you would in a regular meal just because
of the social Factor so one of the
tricks they told me was to try to finish
eating first or make sure you have your
order planned ahead of time so you're
not just giving into the peer pressure
and eating what everybody else is eating
so just by being more aware Noom has
helped me make better decisions in my
life as you guys have known over the
last few months I've lost upwards of 40
pounds just from Noom so I'm still on it
but to be honest I'm also not perfect
it's really hard to do it every single
day and keep it going and logging your
food so one thing that brings me back to
New time and time again is the support
system Jennifer has been an awesome life
coach in Noom and helping me just kind
of giving me articles and tips but
another big motivating factor is you
guys since the last time we did this
I've had a handful of you guys come up
to me in real life and say they were
inspired by Noom or they are now jumping
into their weight loss Journey because
of what they've seen here and that has
been the biggest motivation for me keep
it up for all you guys that got started
because of this I promise to keep it up
to keep you guys going and if you
haven't yet started then you can click
the link in below or go to noom.com
Corridor crew and take your free new
evaluation just like in stocks and
investing I think weight loss and health
is there's no better time to start than
right now thanks to noon for sponsoring
this channel it is one of my favorite
sponsors I'm literally a new Advocate
after all of this stuff so it's been a
huge change in my life and I hope it
helps you guys out too thanks for
watching and uh let's get back to the
react episode man that was that was very
fun that was a lot of stuff to look at
big around and watching this whole video
to the very very end if you enjoy these
videos don't forget to subscribe or head
over to quartotypical.com where we got
the extendo extra long editions of this
react show thanks
see you next one